so we're going to talk about making
humans and code gpu capable today so i'm
emily i'm from atlanta which is the best
city in the world
um
i'm not a data scientist i've spent my
whole career
whole tech career
working alongside data scientists
without actually being one of them
so that's kind of where i see
the empathy of like watching data
scientists do their work
and trying to help empower that
so our goal here
where the highlighting is really off um
our goal here is to help data scientists
do higher quality work
faster that to me is the whole goal of
mlaps is to empower our data scientists
and
in this realm of mlaps this is a hyper
technical field
that is all about people so i'm really
trying to drive this home here like this
is hyper technical but it's all in
service of our data scientists
this is an inherent push pull already in
design trade-offs that we have this
hyper technicality that also has to be
used by people
and this just fits along with a lot of
the other design tradeoffs that we talk
about in our space all the time so jules
had a great little diagram touching on
some of these similar design trade-offs
like
is it friendly for developers or is it
fast for computers that tends to be a
trade-off our spark jobs would be a lot
faster if we were all working in c and
writing inline assembly and you know
messing with p threads and all that kind
of stuff
so raise your hand if you're doing that
right
um
we follow on these different sides of
the spectrum for different reasons um
so with all this kind of
context of design trade-offs uh let's
talk about our typical machine learning
stats i'm presenting this in kind of a
general way but you'll probably
recognize this
um we're all using python it's the
second best language for any task
uh you've got all your python machine
learning libraries um it's probably
containerized you're probably running on
cloud infrastructure you're probably
using kubernetes either directly as in
you're spinning up your own cluster or
indirectly as in
you're using a branded product that is
almost certainly kubernetes under the
hood
so the benefits of this we get great
scalability and we get good
reproducibility if we do this right
so
we really need that kind of ephemeral
scale in femoral infrastructure and big
scalability in our world
so if you're running a web service
like you know mailchimp.com maybe you're
running an all-in-one small business
marketing platform
um
you need
your infrastructure is a lot more steady
state in terms of its traffic so it's
about here and it'll drift up to here
and down to there throughout the day but
it kind of stays in that range
for us with batch jobs and with training
jobs we're either
all on or we're all off there's not a
whole lot in between
serving was a little different but
you get my picture
so we really like this cloud world being
able to spin up and spin down and have
this ephemerality
but there's a problem that comes in when
we have these magical ephemeral
containers that are running
somewhere
and they need to talk to very real gpus
that are not ephemeral and not
virtualized and not made up they are
real actual hardware
so
let's talk about these gpus
um
they're real buzzy you know bitcoin
rendering your video games you can't
really buy them um super hype train
blockchain you know investors love that
um and legitimately they can be really
really awesome so
this is uh
a graph that i'm particularly proud of
for two reasons uh showing what happened
to one of our services when we flipped
on the gpus
the first thing i'm proud of is that
there was zero town time when we did
this which drops
um
but also look what it did to our
response times for that service
that's pretty cool it cut it in like
what
a third or even more
so gpus can be really really helpful for
us
um
to kind of put this in concrete terms
gpus are
optional hardware peripherals
that require really special really
finicky drivers and rely on system buses
for io
so really if you kind of generalize this
gpus or printers
because what is a printer but an
optional hardware peripheral that
requires just super finicky drivers that
are really annoying
so gpus are just printers that are
really good at linear algebra
so hopefully i'm popping the hype bubble
a little bit
um
if we think about
uh
let's talk about what the call stack
would look like if we were running one
of our online services
on an actual physical server so we could
walk on down to the data center you know
see the server poke it
see the actual gpu inside
this is kind of what that call stack
would look like
so the top three layers are kind of
familiar to our data scientist crowd
that's kind of their core area
you've got your service framework that's
underlying your custom python
application that's depending on some
sort of open source machine learning
library
underneath that
and we'll dig into these next two layers
a lot more in just a minute
um you've got your cuda libs
your device drivers
so that's kind of your middle layer
before you hit your operating system
and that operating system is running on
like a physical server that you can poke
and that has a physical gpu in it so
still a lot of layers here
but you know pretty linear in terms of
what we're going to do
so
uh
oh and
you know you can still mentally
substitute gpu for printer
if that helps
in the ephemeral world
this gets a lot more complex so we still
have our same top three layers in green
that are that we've containerized that
we've stuck inside a pod
except that pods are actually life cycle
objects but you know what i mean
and that's running on kubernetes which
is running on a whole bunch of virtual
servers
that are in turn running on like cloud
stuff hypervisors all that jazz
where eventually you get down to a
physical server that eventually has a
physical gpu
um and i kind of cut out all the cuda
lib stuff because it didn't fit on the
slide and because
that's kind of the rub of how do we get
that middle layer in there
so these are kind of the the key pieces
in that middle layer to talk to your gpu
and i do want to caveat really hard here
that i am specifically talking about
nvidia gpus because realistically
they have a monopoly heaven help you if
you were trying to use arm or all that
rock m stuff
it's
it's pretty much in video's world right
now
um
so you have your nvidia gpu um
the next two things you need are your
drivers so you've got a kernel space
driver
and a user space driver so nvidia.k and
libcuda.so is the one you've probably
seen
nvidia calls this their user space
driver most other folks call this the
low level api
on top of that you've got your cuda
toolkit so the key piece here is lib
cuda rt which is your higher level api
and on top of that is stuff that you
might start to recognize like couplas
poo rand to dnn
all that kind of stuff
um
so
we've got to get all those pieces kind
of marshaled into our
containerized system here in order to
make this communication work
so first we're going to get our gpus and
we're going to get our device drivers
from your kubernetes provider so we
happen to be on gcp there's some gke
isms happening in this talk but this
this is probably going to transcend
cloud providers
um
in gke we you can get your gpus just
kind of through your cluster
configuration
you can set them up you can get scaling
gpu pools that's cool
the key part here is this daemon set
that's the second step
so you've got your cluster that's got
some gpus on the back end
what this daemon set does
is
it runs around to every single node in
the cluster
and runs something that's specific to
modifying that node
so this is really perfect in this case
because this daemon set is running
around to install all those device
drivers on the actual node talking to
the nodes operating system
and kind of underneath that kubernetes
layer
um
your cloud provider and your kubernetes
service is going to have some sort of uh
pinned cuda version that it can support
for gke when they took the screenshot it
was 11.0 that might have changed i
haven't checked
um
so that is still it's kind of relatively
straightforward about how we get those
gpus and how we get those device drivers
but that next layer gets a lot more
complex
so
um
when how do we how are we going to get
libku to rt and kind of that cuda
toolkit stuff that we need to support
our machine learning libraries
sometimes
these will ship with your python
libraries
so this is very dependent not only on
the library you're using and how they
choose to package it
but also
what python package manager you're using
because did you know
that pip wheels and condo wheels are not
guaranteed to be one-to-one
and some of the key differences are in
where they package these binaries and
that kind of thing
so
lots and lots of variability here
when these shared objects get shipped
with your python wheel
they're still dynamically linked they're
just packaged in there such that those
shared objects are going to be the first
thing that your dynamic linking path
hits
so
usually this doesn't include the
user lev the user level driver
libcuda.so this is usually everything
above it
so you might walk out it might just come
with the wheel and you you'll be set
or
another option
you might get some of this from your
device driver set and your
kind of what that daemon set that you
installed on your cluster is doing
so in the case of gke it will forward a
whole bunch of nvidia stuff to
things like user local lib nvidia or
something like that
so you can just point your dynamic
library path to that folder
and voila you've got
access to stuff like libcuda
but this usually doesn't have the
toolkit stuff
so
if those two options fail you you're
gonna have to diy it you're gonna have
to install these manually in your
container at build time or build off a
base container that's already got these
installed and already has your dynamic
linking paths kind of set up
more likely you're gonna have to do a
combo of all three of these just
depending on what library you're using
what python package manager you're using
what version of your library you're
using
it's it's wild
so once you've gotten through kind of
where you're going to get these pieces
it's really important to think about
matching your cuda versions all the way
up and down the stack
so what does your gke cluster support
what does your container support in the
stuff that it's got pre-installed
what was your machine learning library
built against and what does it support
so you want to have you know if you're
standardizing on 10.2 you want to have
10.2 in your cluster 10.2 in your
container your library is built against
10.2 you want to match that all the way
up and down the stack
asterisk
usually
sometimes
depending um
this is the stuff is so fun
um
your mileage may vary depending on your
library um
so this is kind of uh
a tale of two deep learning libraries
here
um if you dig around in the pytorch
source code eventually you'll come to
one of these header fire files it's got
one of these great like
300 line comments at the beginning of it
that's like okay you found this header
file and it's kind of nuts and you're
probably wondering what this is and like
okay here's the deal with that and i
just
i love when you find that stuff deep in
this deck um
what it boils down to is that the pie
torch project made a design decision
to support both
cuda 10.2 and 11.0 at the same time
they are doing that
by kind of
wrapping all the cuda toolkit stuff in
their own
like
high torch distribution of that
so when you get the pie torch wheel
it's it is shipping with some binaries
but it's not true bloss and kurand and
all that it is
libku torch
because it's their specific version
that's wrapping both of those
cuda
versions at the same time
and then doing a whole bunch of like
really careful header guarding and if
deathing to support both of those at the
same time
tensorflow
does not
tensorflow uh
is kind of a diva
tensorflow relies each version of
tensorflow relies on extremely specific
versions of all of these underlying
libraries
so extremely specific major versions
and minor versions and sometimes patch
versions and sometimes they don't even
match so you need 10.2 of this but you
need 10.4 of that
so
it has a different experience for us the
end users
um
and just
i guess we're all we're going to wrap
around to the design trade-off
discussion but a moment of design
trade-offs here um
i know which one of these design
trade-offs i prefer as an end user
but
these library developers are in a really
tough situation thinking about how to
manage all this stuff so these are two
equally valid options and really
although as an end user i really prefer
the pytorch method because it makes life
easy for me
those pytorch developers sign themselves
up for a world of tech debt
so like
pity them um
so tensorflow might have the end user
experience of being a house of cards
but
it there's a reason it's like that
um
something else i didn't cover there
uh that's right
so as we're finishing up this discussion
on cuda versions
um
the cuda stack itself has extremely
complex
backward and forward compatibility rules
so kudos always had some form of
backward compatibility along the stack
and then starting in version 10.2
they now have forward compatibility as
well but it's not quite all and up and
down the stack it's like this this
little piece is forward compatible with
that or backward compatible with this so
you can grab these slides later follow
that link
see all the complexities there but
that's just another bit of like
you want the matrikuta versions
sometimes
um
so
a really cool um
trick for helping you get through this
hot mess
uh s trace and l trace so
l trace you can just kind of do like l
trace python invoke my you know awesome
application or whatever um and it'll
show you every single call it's making
to a dynamic or static linked library
um s trace is kind of a similar deal
it's not doing library calls but it's
catching all of your sys calls
importantly
in this which i'm very excited about and
which i'm sure you can't read
it is
going
here i'm using s trace to run my
application and then i'm grepping for a
whole bunch of cuda output and what's
catching for me is every time these
libraries go to get opened
so in this version of that slide which
is still not great but maybe it's a
little better
um
it's going through and it's saying okay
i got limp torch again that's that pie
torch thing it's not shipping poo dnn or
whatever it's shipping its own pie
torchy stuff
um i've got lib torch that's fine i've
got lib torch cuda understood cool
that's fine i've got libku rt i'm
looking for liquid.so and i didn't get
it
so i'm gonna look in a different
directory and i didn't get it and i'm
gonna look at the different directory
and i didn't get it and that whole long
output slide is just searching for
libcuda.so and not finding it which
for me lets me know aha you can't find
libtruder.so and the library level error
messages probably didn't tell me that
because this ecosystem is great
um
so that's kind of the technical piece of
how do we enable
code to be gpu capable
now the second piece of this is how do
we enable this for people
because what i don't want to do is go to
all of our data scientists and be like
cool okay let me give you a presentation
about gpus and lib cuda and let you just
have this knowledge and go figure it out
that's not the best thing
because there's typically this gap
between a typical data scientist system
needs
and the typical data scientists system
knowledge and experience
or if you have some of those unicorn
data scientists like we do a mailchimp
who do have that lower level stack
experience
you can substitute in here
their ability to focus on so many pieces
of the stack at the same time
because heaven knows data scientists
have a lot going on at the top of the
stack they've got to think about the
implications of their models all these
statistical fallacies
you know there's a whole discipline to
data science that doesn't involve these
underneath layers of the stack
so
that's what i think of as us coming in
as mlops professionals is filling that
gap
so that we can enable data scientists to
do higher quality work faster
and we want to do this through
systems abstraction
data scientists don't need low code they
need low systems
because they can write code
they're developers they can write code
that's not the problem
so what we want to do here with systems
abstraction is to provide a good enough
encapsulation layer so that they can
keep their focus at this top of the
stack where it belongs
systems encapsulation is
really hard
particularly in our ecosystem that's so
young and so
kind of evolving and maturing out from
under us
so it's very very common to have some
systems encapsulation it's like okay
we've got this totally covered but it's
going to spring a leak for this
particular thing so like we're all good
until you need to find the logs for that
thing and oh you need to find the logs
for that thing okay let me install cube
cuddle and teach you how to use it and
you know
you all know that
um
so just to visualize this
the green is the top of the stack that's
where we're trying to keep our data
scientists everything else is what we're
trying to encapsulate not because
they're too dumb but because they have
too much else to focus on and we are
trying to accelerate them
so
this tends to invoke a design trade-off
between being too opinionated or too
configurable
jules again was kind of talking on this
in this last talk about ray
if it's too opinionated you can't get it
to do what you need to do if it's too
configurable
you can't get it to do what you need to
do
for different reasons
um as a concrete example you could think
about app engine is very opinionated app
engine is very easy to use it's
serverless you just give it your code
it goes and runs that somewhere it
scales whatever and it doesn't have gpus
so it's too opinionated and it's too
limited for what we needed to do
on the other hand to configurable
again it's probably not the best design
choice to just hand your data scientists
a raw kubernetes cluster and say good
luck it can do what you need it to do if
you can get it there
so we're trying to hit that sweet spot
in the middle of how do we do enough
systems encapsulation
such that there's still room to do more
configuration if needed
so to do this and enable this kind of
high tech stuff we went super low tech
so are y'all ready for the big reveal to
get gpu capability we do
repo templating
isn't that exciting
um
so it's
repo templating is not cool it's not
like you know we're not gonna have a
conference about repo templating but it
works it really really works
we found this to be
the right level of abstraction for our
data scientists to give them a stable
base from which they can go off and
extend and do the work that they need to
do
so for us at mailchimp some of the stuff
that's included in our repo template um
based containers to kind of encapsulate
the systems level stuff
places to integrate your custom python
code some starter like requirements
files
basic run scripts for your application
some basic ci cd stuff
so that there is ci cd
because there may not be if we didn't
provide that
um
and we get this gpu capability basically
at the container layer in this template
so both at the kubernetes layer which i
didn't really talk about but
in the pod configuration when you're
attaching that gpu we provide that
templating and then we also provide a
base container that is
mostly gpu capable for whatever machine
learning library you want to throw at it
so
some challenges we've encountered with
this are
is your base container general enough
um and what we found is that
one of the reasons i know that
tensorflow is a diva is that
it's not general enough to support
whatever version of tensorflow
so that's been the challenge that we've
encountered
there's also some design decisions you
have to make when you consider
the kind of common applications that a
data scientist needs to produce so a
python library versus a batch job versus
an online service um do you want to cram
all of that into one repo template do
you want to split it out
um
if you've got this template that's kind
of like your source of truth for how we
do this and you get a bug fix to it how
do you update children of that template
interesting and surprisingly kind of
deep challenge there
um
and then we kind of talked about the gpu
capability piece of this so
a little hard one wisdom uh this is i
guess our no bs data conference
um
we found that rather than trying to cram
everything into one template type it's
better to have multiple templates
and if you if you as kind of the team
that provides the stuff want to have
your own like underlying layer of stuff
that's all the same cool but what you
present to the data scientist is more
kind of split out about like here's your
library starter base and it's it may
have a lot of similar components but it
is different from your batch job
interface
and that kind of thing
um
we really have learned that we
should we kind of cannot and should not
limit our data scientists in their
choice of library it's really really
important for us to empower data
scientists however they need to be
empowered and that does not include
saying
oh you can only use pytorch because
tensorflow is a diva it means figuring
out how do we support tensorflow because
our data we're trusting our data
scientists to make a reasonable choice
and to be asking for this if because
they have a really darn good reason for
it
um
we found that having one base container
that's kind of the data science
container
really isn't good enough um it's really
better to have a curated list of options
from which you can pick accompanied by
some good documentation that covers this
gpu stuff
well enough for folks to make an
informed decision
um
and then finally
when we're doing these templates um when
we first run on the templating train it
was like oh yeah template everything
it's great
um and then found that we were trying to
generalize too hard and trying to
generalize over some weird stuff
so design it for the 90 case and leave
room for the 10 percenters to go do
weird stuff but don't try to wrap their
weird stuff into the template it's too
confusing
um so that's basically what i've got for
you all today uh
on the tet side and on the human side
just some final thoughts
to hammer at home one more time ml ops
is a hyper technical field
that is all about people we do all of
this in service of empowering our data
scientists to move fast and get great
insights for our business and to do the
work they need to do
do it faster and do it to a higher
degree of quality
um
a totally different level uh when you're
confused about gpu stuff uh and cuda
weirdness as trace and l trace are your
friends
repo templating is also your friends
um
and
just in general
don't be afraid to be uncool to do cool
stuff repo templating it's not cool
um
so that's what i got for y'all today i'm
happy to take questions now and i did
want to mention that on the schedule my
office hours are going to be after lunch
so just fyi i will be there but after
lunch so
thank you
[Applause]